sunday mass is something that happens
every week
these weeks it feels different
father pavlo droziak says looking out at
his parishioners he can tell they're
tired
it's 11th day of war
all of us is so scary
because we don't know what does it mean
war
now we know
the people in saint george's cathedral
on this day have been dealing with air
raid sirens and checkpoints but so far
the actual fighting hasn't come here yet
no one thinks it can't many think it
will
putin
this woman tells us what vladimir putin
is doing is terrible she asks how her
beautiful country can be destroyed
but the people who came to mass on this
date there was a message they were told
to do what they can to help
prayer alone isn't enough
we believe in god and also we believe in
our country
but we need to do something
believe without doing it's nothing
this woman has been weaving camouflage
covers for hiding vehicles and says
everyone is mobilized she came to church
today she says not to pray for herself
but for everyone she knows
there is a pressure in this city almost
an extra emotional weight there's worry
about what might come and worry about
friends and family in other parts of the
country they're also families that have
been split up
somebody that's the same this woman
tells us she sent her children to poland
while this couple left their home on the
first day of the war
when we
were exiting kiev we hear
bombs
but
not so comfortable feeling when you pack
just
one backpack
and you don't know where to go what to
do you just leave
now that cathedral we visited is going
to be doing something tomorrow they
haven't done since the second world war
father droziak told us they're going to
be taking down statues and artwork in
case there's bombing they're going to be
wrapping it and moving it into the
basement colleen
mike armstrong in la vie of ukraine
thanks mike